we are learning new information about
how houston police found a missing tiger
that was seen
roaming around a neighborhood last week
police say the bengal tiger named
india was unharmed when it was turned
over to authorities on saturday it is
now at a wildlife sanctuary near dallas
janet chamblin has been following this
story but we got him
and he's healthy houston's missing tiger
has been
found a tiger in my neighborhood the big
cat had been the subject of an
exhaustive search
since he was seen leisurely prowling a
residential street
at one point the 175 pound animal coming
face to face
with an off-duty deputy
the nine-month-old bengal was then
driven away investigators say by victor
hugo cuevas
wavis was later arrested for evading
police but the cat remained elusive
now new details on how india was found
and it involves the wife of well-known
houston businessman and philanthropist
jim mackinvale
known as mattress mack linda mcinvale
the owner of an athletic club that
houses exotic animals
so she's an acquaintance of cuevas and
his wife and convinced them
to turn the tiger over i think they were
very worried about where the cat would
go and so i feel like they
probably felt like because they knew me
could trust me that my assurance that it
would go someplace good was good for
them
this morning the big cat is at a texas
animal sanctuary
after a 30-day quarantine he'll be moved
to a half-acre plot
with a pool and trees while he is
playful at this age as an adult
he can be deadly and so it's our goal to
not have these animals as pets
victor cuevas's attorney insists that
cuevas is not the owner of the tiger
however
linda mackinvale told us that she and
cuevas's wife
turned over the tiger on saturday here
at this athletic club
which doubles as an animal sanctuary
thus the flamingos
houston police say they are trying to
figure out where the tiger has been
for the past week gail that was great
thus
the flamingos nicely done janet shamley
and we're just glad the tiger is going
to be released
looks so sad in that cage thank you very
much janet